[Musique]
c'est dans ce vieil hôtel de calgary
preston manning nous a donné rendez-vous
77 ans l'ancien chef du parti réformiste
revient à l'avant-scène défendre les
intérêts de l'ouest du pays il son
discours n'a pas changé les gens dans
l'ouest sont furieux créatif ne sentent
pas que le gouvernement fédéral
travaille pour eux ils voient ottawa
comme un adversaire pas comme un allié
on n'est pas loin de ce qu'il disait
déjà en 1991
car selon preston manning le sentiment
d'aliénation qui minent l'alberta et la
saskatchewan est profondément ancré dans
l'histoire des deux provinces
au moment de la confédération l'ouest
canadien était considérée comme une
colonie par l'ontario et le québec
l'alberta et la saskatchewan ne
contrôlait pas leurs ressources
naturelles contrairement aux autres
provinces
il a fallu attendre les années 30 pour
que ça change
un bon exemple de l'état d'esprit à
l'époque cette caricature publiée dans
un journal des prairies en 1915 elle
montre des fermiers de l'ouest en train
de nourrir une vache
il est du pays qui en tirent tous les
profits aujourd'hui le rapport de forces
est plus équilibrée concept preston
manning
mais l'ouest continuent de ne pas sentir
apprécié à sa juste valeur
d'où l'importance dit-il du comité créé
il ya quelques jours par jason kenny
pour renforcer l'autonomie de l'alberta
si la fédération ne veut pas nous aider
dit il
nous allons prendre les choses en main
province étudie la possibilité de se
doter de son propre régime de retraite
d'une agence de revenu unique et d'un
corps de police albertain pour ne plus
dépendre la grc
bref on s'inspire du québec je pense
qu'il ya de la jalousie envers ce qui se
passe au québec on voit les pouvoirs que
le québec a obtenu ont fait le du temps
et on se dit nous aussi on devrait avoir
la même chose sauf qu'on tient pas
compte du fait que le québec a une
langue une culture distincte
on revient à la logique de chaque
province devrait être égale pour le chef
du nouveau parti indépendantiste de
l'ouest le oui exit il y a tellement de
colère en ce moment en alberta que tu
sèmes kenny n'a pas le choix de parler
d'autonomie selon ce politologue
jason kenny est plutôt en train
d'utiliser le sentiment autonomistes à
son avantage en se présentant comme
celui qui peut modérer les ardeurs
examen dépendantes east pour moi jason
kenny agit comme robert bourassa
l'ancien premier ministre du québec à la
fin des années 80 qui disait au reste du
canada
moi je suis fédéraliste mais si vous
n'adhérez pas à nos demandes
vous risquez de vous retrouver avec
jacques parizeau un souverainiste m
des newcomers c'est aussi ce que pense
preston manning la colère des alter
femme ne doit pas être ignoré l'api
réaction de l'establishment serait de
faire abstraction de la frustration de
ces alberta mécontents en se disant tout
simplement qu'ils sont ignorants et
stupide
on risquerait conclut-il de galvaniser
encore davantage le ressentiment des
albertains envers leur pays
ici l'heure en sortait radio canada à
calgary